Demos sprechöre Verhaftung im Iran
brodelt es nach dem Tod einer
22-jährigen Frau reißen die Proteste im
Land nicht ab es ist der unermüdliche
Kampf gegen die strengen Sittengesetze
der Mulas
es sind Bilder die um die Welt gehen
mutiger Iranerin reißen sich ihre
Kopftücher von den Haaren und verbrennen
sie auf offener Straße es sind mutige
Frauen die die strengen
frauenfeindlichen Sittengesetze der
Mullahs nicht mehr akzeptieren wollen
Auslöser der aktuellen Proteste der Tod
der 22 Jahre alten Mascha armini sie
wird vor zwei Wochen von der iranischen
Sittenpolizei festgenommen und das nur
weil sie angeblich ihr Kopftuch nicht
richtig trägt
auf der Polizeistation fällt sie ins
Koma ausgelöst durch Schläge der Polizei
die Behörden weisen jedoch diese Version
zurück sprechen von Herzproblemen
drei Tage nach ihrer Verhaftung am 16
September stirbt Mascha Amini im
Krankenhaus an ihren Verletzungen
seither ist der Iran in Aufruhr
[Applaus]
mit brutaler Härte gehen die
Sicherheitskräfte gegen die
Freiheitskämpfer vor schlagen auf die
Demonstranten ein Schießen mit scharfer
Munition in die Menge verhaften tausende
und schalten das Internet ab
immer öfter bezahlen DemonstrantInnen
ihren Kampf für die Freiheit mit dem
Leben schon 50 Tote sind es seit dem
Beginn der Proteste weltweit
solidarisieren sich die Menschen mit dem
Aufstand im Iran fordern die Absetzung
des grausamen iranischen mullerregimes
und wollen konkrete Hilfeleistungen so
zum Beispiel Elon Musk der reichste
Mensch der Welt möchte sein Starling
Satellitensystem zur Verfügung stellen
heißt die Iraner bekommen wohl bald
Internet aus dem All ohne dass die
Mullahs es abschalten können ein
weiterer Hoffnungsschimmer für die
mutigen Frauen und Männer die im Iran
für ihre Freiheit auf die Straße gehen
und dabei alles riskieren
[Musik]
im Iran haben die Molas ihr das Singen
verboten die Ikone der iranischen
Popmusik gogusch hat am Wochenende ein
seltenes Konzert gegeben und zwar in
Deutschland sie ist die Helene Fischer
der Iraner und Fans freuten sich über
eine Auswahl ihrer bekanntesten Hits sie
äußerte sich auch zu den aktuellen
Demonstrationen im Land dass sie in den
USA lebende Sängerin selbst nicht mehr
betreten kann
[Musik]
und wie du in
sie singt von Liebe Sehnsucht und
Freiheit am Freitagabend gab die in den
USA lebende Exil Iranerin gogusch ein
Konzert in Hamburg und widmete es Mass
so Amini der jungen Frau die von der
iranischen Sittenpolizei verhaftet und
totgeprügelt wurde die Sicherheitskräfte
gehen weiterhin brutal vor und Schießen
auf unbewaffnete Demonstranten mehr als
50 Demonstranten sind schon tot und es
gibt tausende Festnahmen
Bildsprache mit googoosh am Rande ihres
abschiedskonzertes in Deutschland
die iranischen Frauen haben das Recht
auf Freiheit über das Tragen des
Kopftuchs selbst zu entscheiden
[Applaus]
aber leider hat Massa Amini erst mit
ihrem Tod ihrer Tötung diesen Weg für
die iranischen Frauen eröffnet diese
Bewegung ist ein Weg den eine
unschuldige 22-jährige Frau ermöglicht
hat denn ich glaube es ist nun die Zeit
der Frauen gekommen besonders der Frauen
meiner Heimat
vor der Revolution hatten die Menschen
ein Leben in Wohlstand somit war das
Leben von uns allen und allen Künstlern
im Iran ideal wir waren alle im
Aufschwung ich war zu der Zeit eine der
erfolgreichsten Künstler meines Landes
ich habe sowohl gesungen und war auch
als Schauspielerin tätig ich war wie
gesagt in verschiedensten Bereichen
aktiv
alles endete nach 1979
für 21 Jahre habe ich alles zur Seite
gelegt
nach vorne geschafft an der marmoli
als ich nach 21 Jahren wieder die Bühne
betrat fühlte es sich wie das erste mal
an wie ein Amateur der vor so einem
großen Publikum auftreten musste
es ist die Pflicht eines jeden Künstlers
egal ob Sänger Schauspieler Maler oder
Schriftsteller egal ob im Iran oder
außerhalb Irans wir können mit unserer
Botschaft mit einer Einladung zum
Beisammensein mit den iranischen Frauen
die gerade auf den Straßen kämpfen und
ihre Kopftücher abnehmen haben um sie zu
unterstützen damit sie sich nicht
zurückziehen und keine Angst haben
weiter vorangehen um für ihr Recht zu
kämpfen
ich glaube nicht dass das Regime den
Menschen ein Referendum zur Wahl stellt
das glaube ich nicht hoffe aber dass ein
Referendum zustande kommt damit das Volk
entscheiden kann ein diktatorisches
Regime ein religiös diktatorisches
Regime das bereits jahrelang alle
einsperrt und alle eingeengt hat ein
normales Leben welches das Recht von
jedem Menschen ist die Entscheidung wie
erleben sich anziehen möchte denken
möchte das wurde ihm genommen
ich freue mich und ich bin voller
Hoffnung dass ich für das iranische Volk
besonders die iranischen Frauen alles
zum Guten wendet
mich schon
[Musik]
[Applaus]